we're going to segue to a new story a
story from the New York Post it's titled
death of shot Clinton aide with Epstein
ties found tied to tree ruled suicide
despite no gun at seen and I want to say
to all of you who are watching this show
and our fans I wanted to open tonight's
show with this story but the big news is
obviously Trump coming down that matters
a lot more to people because it's
directly impacting the lives of people
who are facing this toxic spill so I can
respect that and as much as the Clinton
Aid being tied by the neck to a tree and
found shot to death with no gun being
ruled a suicide well this is not
immediately going to impact your life
but it is very very interesting so let
me just let me just stress that again an
individual who worked the clintons uh in
the 90s was found tied to a tree shot in
the chest no gun and they went looks
like a suicide to me so uh I guess he
held the gun to his chest and when he
pulled the trigger it The Recoil blasted
off into the air where it landed on on a
small log in the river and then floated
Downstream and eventually over waterfall
where it's just gone maybe he might have
had balloons tied to his gun that's a
good point that could have been a good
one he had he had several 100 balloons
tied to the gun because obviously the
gun would probably weigh several pounds
did the Warren Commission do this or
somebody's like it's like it's like the
Phantom gun Theory you know what I mean
like if you're tied to a tree and you've
got gunshots is it more than one gunshot
or is it just one I think is it two well
I think it just said that he was shot
and he was shot in the chest right
that's what it was Phil I don't know so
if even if you have a pistol and you're
doing that kind of an extension cord
tying his neck to a tree with a gunshot
wound to the chest that's what it says I
wonder what kind of gunshot right oh
they could you could you imagine like if
this if if this was a suicide and he
strapped balloons to his gun for for
okay come on like clearly he did not do
that clearly this is probably just not a
suicide
um maybe there's a bunch of things you
can say maybe two right let's let's play
this game how or could someone sorry so
he goes up against a tree and he throws
the extension cord around it and then
catches it on the other side and then
ties it and Spins it around so that way
he's tied by the neck then he takes we
don't know kind of gun hold it to his
chest when he pulls the trigger at this
point several things may have occurred
the gun recoil launched into the air
where I mentioned it lands on a log and
then floats away Downstream to never be
seen again or maybe a bear came and Like
Cocaine bear you saw the gun and thought
to himself with this I will rule the
forest picks the gun up and then walks
away
in reality maybe someone found the gun
and was like hey that's worth money and
then just took it and ran but let's just
play Occam's razor in the absence of
evidence The Simple Solution tends to be
the correct one someone shot him that's
it and took the gun away and right and
then walked away with it
I can't believe that that's even a
headline I I can't believe that that
actually people are expecting to believe
that I mean I I suppose after the
Epstein stuff you know they figure just
whatever I would like I would like to
hear the numbers of the people of the
number of people that commit suicide by
shooting themselves in the chest you
know what I'm saying because I don't
think that from what I've read about
this situation about people who do that
they want it over quickly right if you
shoot yourself in the chest unless you
get yourself right in the heart
it's still a slow process right and so I
I think that should be a question that
they ask as well it's like and not to
mention just the sheer mechanics of if
it was a rifle that it was done with it
well the cop said they found 12 gauge
buckshot in his car and a gun case with
no gun
so then like did he have a shotgun that
is incredibly difficult to do if you I
mean a shotgun is a long long rifle uh
weapon 18-inch barrel that's why the SP
SBS that's why the the the typical story
is you use your foot yeah that they they
aim with their feet or whatever I don't
want to give away too much please nobody
hurt yourself at home or anything like
that but uh yeah I I what he I'm sorry
it The Recoil launched us into the air
where it attached to a like a bird
catches it and flies away with it he
tied balloons to it I mean that's that's
the only logical explanation that these
cops are to be right or how about this
this guy is involved in something
and somebody killed him I mean for all
we know look let's be real for all we
know he's banging some dude's wife right
it could be that simple we don't need we
don't need to go back 30 years and be
like here with the clintons he did and
maybe he banged some dude's wife and
someone got revenge on him maybe it was
a sheriff's wife but the sad part about
this is that this is going to put an end
to the to any real questioning about
this you know you may have the people
like us talking about it but it's in
terms of official investigation this is
done because nobody else has
jurisdiction anything about the clintons
is done before it gets started it's true
what's the Epstein ties did you guys he
assigned Epstein into the White House
apparently like a dozen times something
like that
see I don't think that someone was going
to commit suicide would tie their neck
around a tree first yeah it was very
weird or tie balloons to the gun I mean
unless he was just like I hate this
world and I'm gonna confuse the hell out
of everybody I looked up uh New York
Post Clinton AIDS suicide and it gave me
other people's names as well Mark Rich
Vince Foster Mark Middleton Mark
Middleton that's who it was not Mark
Richman Vince Foster yeah I mean twice
in the back of the head or something
like that it was there was uh who was
the guy who was the journalist who was
investigating the CIA or whatever like
the crack stuff and then he got shot
twice in the head and they rolled it a
suicide
you want to look that one up yeah
what was that guy's name like there's
just so many of these stories and then
uh I was mentioning I've been watching
Yellowstone and so this isn't really a
spoiler because this is like first
season first episode stuff but they kill
a lot of people in that show and they
just kick them off a mountain and it's
like ain't nobody gonna find these
people you know this is Gary Webb is
that Gary Webb two gunshots to the Head
rule to suicide by the Sacramento County
coroner's office and that's it for that
investigation okay you know what I mean
that's done it could be like in South
Park there was that episode where the
guy was trying to kill himself and then
shoots himself like oh oh no I'm still
alive and then he keeps trying or
whatever like okay whatever but I just I
got Occam's razor this one and just be
like typically when someone's shot twice
in the head it's not a suicide so why
would they be like nah you know suicides
or whatever jeez Gary Webb wrote what is
this the dark Alliance series uh examine
the origins of the crack cocaine trade
in Los Angeles and anti-communist Contra
Rebels and Nicaragua yeah you know we
don't want people finding out about that
so drug trade feeling who knows what
Stories the CIA is selling crack and
cocaine in in the United States do you
think what percentage of our economy you
think is like drugs is that taking
Pharma would that take I mean I think
big Pharma accounts for like probably 10
some ridiculous number I think the
healthcare industry itself is 20 is huge
but that's but that's not just drugs
yeah those are those are illicit drugs
not illness no no it's not all drugs the
the 20 of the economy is medical meaning
like when you go to a doctor to get your
legs set you know or get you know
ibuprofen for your bad headaches mental
health yes yeah and all the Praises for
that are all inflated because the
government being involved and and stuff
in here there's no Market you know in
the US but yeah
well you think like this this drug trade
from Central America is like a portion
of the economy that like black budget
economy we just don't know about of
course they get exposed of course I
think it is I mean there's there's
always dark money you know and it comes
from all sources but when you when you
get into situations like this just like
Tim was saying you know it could it
could not be Clinton related uh it's
like look this guy went to the Clinton
30 30 some odd years ago right they're
bringing up he was a Clinton aide
because of the conspiracy theory and
that's what I've said about the
conspiracy theory and the clintons are
high profile people who've worked in
multiple agencies and in government of
course they're gonna have connections to
a lot of people now the question is take
someone of comparable public stature and
then calculate how many deaths and
suicides have exist around them in their
periphery and then do that several times
is it different I think what happens is
yeah the clintons are shady people
but it's just like I've seen stories
where it's like a security guard who
worked for a financial firm that Clinton
once used was found dead and I'm like
okay well hold on there buddy we're
getting a bit Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon
on this one did they work with them or
with their organizations if there's a
lot of that that's weird but they're
just bringing up a guy who died recently
and being like he worked for the
clintons 30 years ago and it's like
you're telling me that he still works
for the clintons or something well and
this is just compounded by the whole
Epstein connection I mean they're still
trying to claim that he you know killed
himself right I mean and you know all
the tapes just weren't working all the
videos weren't working this should say
former Clinton aide Minsk says Tim don't
forget to give the disclaimer talk to a
doctor and find out if associated with
the clintons is right for you I think
the doctor would say no no no don't do
that didn't he die in Arkansas too is
that what it was that's what I think was
really yeah he Perryville Arkansas May
2nd 2022 almost one year after his death
a police report obtained by the outlet
revealed that the Little Rock
businessman was discovered with a
gunshot wound to the chest and extension
cord tying his neck to a tree 3. the
extension cord was tied to the tree a
tree limb above him so did he like throw
it over and then like slip knot it pull
it tied around his neck and then lean
back and then shoot himself like you
know could this be auto-erotic
asphyxiation gone wrong I mean you know
like I mean it just it just seems so
very strange maybe the real story is
that like it was auto erotic
asphyxiation but then like a loved one
was like I can't let it be known that he
died this way so they shoot him when he
was already dead
yeah it's an explanation there was some
celebrity who died from that and they
wouldn't admit it they were like oh is
it a heroin singer nxs was it was it
really I think it was the singer in
excess he was joking himself while
choking president this is the
family-friendly show so was it Cornell
was Cornell doing that too I don't think
so no okay good yeah I think that was
heroin I think Chris yeah I think that
was heroin wasn't he died on an airplane
it was a suit I heard it was a suicide I
don't I had never heard the about cause
of death though so is that an all
overdose or something
no I don't know I don't know I've also
heard other stories about what that
might have been so I'm gonna not get
into enough Cornell yeah not just that
but like a lot of other people too it's
just you know us of course
dark and Not So Family yeah you think
that having the word Clinton in the
headline of this is sensationalist yes
absolutely yeah absolutely
sensationalist journalism is destroying
the universe yes
destroying the universe well I think
it's destroying our political system I
think I think that everything is about
getting clicks and and you have this
giant push for okay how many CL and this
is right and left that's what gets so
fresh I live in a red State okay and and
politicians or just journalists will
automatically put out the most
Sensational headline that they can and
the the body of the story has nothing to
do with what the headline has to do and
this is in red States you know and it
gets very frustrating for people who
like myself are just trying to find the
truth about what's actually happening in
your community and because all this
stuff becomes smoke and mirrors and I
think that Republicans taking kind of
the woke the the woke cue from things
from 2019 2020 when everything just got
out of hand have said well we're just
going to jump on the bad wagon you know
conservative media sometimes does that
and I think it's it's not doing us any
favors it's not doing us any favors to
actually find out the truth of what's
going on that's kind of like if if a
weapon was given to your opponent your
the opposing Army but what the weapon
does is hurt everyone a little bit right
and they use it and they use it you're
like well that thing is destroying us we
need it too so then you start using it
everyone's getting hurt I mean it's
everyone you're people too right that's
what it feels like and you're so it's
self-harm over time because then people
stop trusting you you know and the more
the politicians dig into that you get in
in the local communities you know in
places like Oklahoma you just lose trust
for for the people that you've elected
and you know these people right these
are your local elected officials but
they're participating as much as as
anybody on the national level sometimes
more the disassociation and not trusting
and not knowing your uh local
politicians I think is something that
that people in cities are familiar with
and used to whereas people in small
towns it's easier to access your your
local politicians if there's only five
thousand ten thousand people in your
town as opposed to if you're you know in
New York City or in Cleveland Ender or
whatever you know like people in we're
talking about
um East Palestine there's only 5 000 of
them they can they can access the
politicians and let them know that
they're upset really easily they can but
it's a that's a double-edged sword
because sometimes you get local
politicians who are friends with
everybody sure and right and they will
just
say what everything it kind of on the on
the blanket of that trust on the
foundation of that trust and oftentimes
you'll see if you really investigate it
that what they're saying is not
necessary and I'm not talking about
anybody specifically I'm just saying
I've seen this over and over again where
they use this Hometown Spirit okay if
you're running in this District you've
got 10 000 people in your District you
know all their names you know all the
families and you go out and you say you
know well this is what this bill does
and you actually read the bill and it
does the complete opposite
that that gets weaponized too and so I I
would just encourage anybody from my
experience read your bills your local
bills because they're the ones that uh
the local laws that are passed on your
behalf from your local politicians
because those are the ones that directly
affect you yeah make sure they're doing
what it is they say they're doing I've
been thinking about sensationalizing the
titles of our show like this show
because like what if the name of the
show is just number 713 and would we get
as many views Lex Friedman we might not
we might get more yeah exactly because
Lexus shows off the chains popular Rogan
he doesn't put any he just puts the name
of the person in the video and the
number huge views like if you know the
person you trust them and you like it's
it's more about the people than about
what the what right but but you come to
timcast to find out because I think this
show has done a great job I started
watching around 2020. you know and I'm
and you're a left-leaning person I was
more right-leaning right and I I
appreciated the fact that I could see
what you were talking about and then I
could see your mind change you know on
different things that that that it
opened up you were opening up people's
eyes while you were opening up people's
eyes about things and I think that
that's the benefit of having that kind
of if you want to call it sensationalism
you know on a show like this it's it's
because you hit people from all sides
here you know what I mean it's it's this
is this is a topical cultural commentary
and political commentary and news
commentary right if we were just a show
about
talking to each other and having a
hangout the titles will be very
different
so that's why let's Lex Friedman's show
is literally him talking to a guy Joe
Rogan is him talking to a person or I
shouldn't say a guy but people so it's
just the the name of the person and
that's and that's what you go for so the
new show that we're doing you know
Fridays culture war with Tim Poole
youtube.com timcast is probably just
going to be titled culture War number
one Ali London culture War number two
guest guest guest to come because those
are just conversations in Hangouts I
guess do you do you stress about being
too sensationalist when you make
internet video titles a little bit we've
talked about it before I mean I've got
my limit clearly the most successful
channels on YouTube have no qualms
whatsoever about saying the craziest
garbled nonsense you know what one thing
Mr Beast does really well is his titles
will be outlandishly awesome but then in
the first 10 seconds he'll back up the
title he'll let you know this you are
about to see what the title says it's
this get ready so you know like your
your expectations are met right away
apparently that's a huge part of as with
many things there are people who
naturally are Sensational and they have
no idea what they're doing and why it
works but they get a lot of traffic then
there are people who consciously try to
figure out how to create better better
titles and headlines to attract more
people and they get called scummy for
being manipulative it's like well should
we just leave it to those who are
accidentally manipulating people or
should people make headlines that are
attractive I have I have a limit you
know clearly uh but they're strangely
we've had instances where it's like the
new story is you know Donald Trump
delivers Big Macs like I'll make the the
title just that and someone will be like
clickbait and I'll be like click click
what you did refers to omitting
information from a title in order to get
people to click it so that they can
figure out what's going on rage bait is
a reference to intentionally over hyping
something to shock people make them
angry so they click it and then and then
watch and then of course you know click
bait could also refer to if uh Donald
you know Joe Biden's trips going up the
stairs titling the video Joe Biden has
horrific fall
nearly dies and then it's a video of him
stumbling and going like that's most of
the internet though thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time